le service de santé des armées va
travailler à développer un certain
nombre de grands centres de vaccination
pour les appeler vaccinodromes ou méga
centre quel que soit le quel que soit le
nom il ya au moins 35 centres qui vont
être déployés à la fois par l'armée les
pompiers sur le territoire national je
ne suis pas du tout certain que ça doit
france c'est mon opinion
la forme de grands stades dans lesquels
viendrait faire la queue des milliers de
personnes en plein hiver les livraisons
de vaccins augmente et donc nous nous
nous tenons prêts pour que à mesure que
les deux arrivent sur le territoire
elles puissent être proposés aux
français le plus vite possible pour les
protéger il nous n'avons pas encore de
données suffisamment solide sur le fait
que le vaccin préserverait de la
transmission du virus
[Musique]